Derrick Rose I've been watching you for a long [time]
You're the three-eyed bird. No, that's larry
What is this place? Where are we north?
Carolina where the hornets of the forest we were here long before the bobcats [I]?
seek your wisdom
So that I may be a great ball like you once where I can teach you how to fly
like an Eagle
You must trust your teammates
Learn from your failures and whatever you do
Don't try baseball thank you. I'm so grateful. [I] kneel before you no no no no no not the knees
Are you lonely?
Just bored were you bored a lot too in the NBA no, I was a starter. Are you ashamed of me father?
When you were drafted hopes for you [were] high, but you start quickly plummeted
Everyone advised me not to make the trade and let you live out your short career in New Orleans. I
Told them all to go to hell
Because you did not belong cross the world with the bloody pelicans. You [are] the former first-team all-Acc
McDonald's all-American Naismith Prep player of the year and
You are my son
Does this mean I get to start next year? Let's not get crazy
and
Kyle Lowry Cos
Brutus six with all his [bitter]
was
and so he choked and so he choked [then] lord of
Tehran
Destroy Rubbish
No more yeah, play em play the tale of the big three [-] happy [sorry] about John inches
When the cow [six] [won] in 2008 it was all about all Kevin and read
three great men for Gavin [to] [play] and a bunch of other [role] players all Kevin
Racing with me now
one more time
Enough I'm sick of it that team was nothing without me. I was off in
legend in Boston yeah me A
Legend but I like that song you should shut you and hold your ginger head
So I could piss in any gutter and score more points than five of you I
Wouldn't stand a chance
None of us would I wouldn't go that far
Who the hell was that?
It's no wonder they kicked you out of dallas. There's a special place for lonely trash talkers like yourself
And like this guy and where the hell, do you suppose that is?
It's the black Mamba
Los Angeles